you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
a boost for nuclear power as the
government injects a 100 million pounds
into size well see
how the conflict between russia and
ukraine could affect the future of
europe's gas supply
and a rare winter storm in the middle
east blankets the region in snow
shutting down public services and
leaving refugees struggling to survive
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
now plans for a new nuclear power
project size well c have been given a
100 million pound cash injection by the
government while ministers believe more
nuclear power will boost the uk's energy
resilience climate activists say this
grant shows it's not a commercially
viable source of energy
so let's take a closer look at the role
of nuclear power in the uk's future
energy makeup now as you can see from
this graph nuclear power peaked here in
the late 90s when 17 nuclear power
stations were operational and generating
over a quarter of the uk's electricity
but in 2021 nuclear accounted for just
14 percent of electricity in great
britain generated by the eight nuclear
power station sites shown here
and almost half of the country's current
capacity is to be retired by 2025.
they'll be replaced by potentially three
reactors hinckley point c
bradwell b and sizewell c which has just
received 100 million pounds to continue
development of the site
now sizewell c will produce 3.2
gigawatts of electricity that should
amount to approximately seven percent of
the country's needs well our science and
technology editor tom clark joins us now
so tom what does this 100 million pound
cash injection from the government tell
us about their nuclear ambitions
well this is seen as a vote of
confidence from the government in size
well c and that's significant for two
main reasons firstly
almost every analyst you speak to says
we are going to need some amount of
nuclear power and a lot more than we've
already got to meet our net zero targets
by 2050. right now we're spending quite
a lot of money to switch on gas power
stations sometimes even coal power
stations on cold windy days like we're
seeing from time to week sorry cold
windless days like we're seeing at the
moment when
renewable energy from wind when solar
power is not available you need extra
baseline energy that's low carbon or
zero carbon on your grid to meet net
zero nuclear quite rightly claim they
are a very good contender for supplying
that energy so a very confidence inside
of lc makes it more likely that it's
going to come on stream and we'll get
that bit closer to our net zero
ambitions for the grid as a whole the
other reason this hundred million is
important it shows there's willingness
it shows it demonstrates willingness to
the investment community
because the other thing that nuclear has
got to prove it wants to be a contender
is it can be value for money an edf who
are building or proposing to build size
well c
need i've got quite a lot of work to do
in that regard because hinckley point c
its sister reactor
which should have been completed in 2017
is still under construction isn't
expected now to be completed until 2026
it's gone colossally over budget
and they have to make a case that we're
not going to see similar cost overruns
and similar burdens on the bill pairs
due to costs from size well c the
government are putting forward a
different funding model for size well c
that takes less of the risk um out of it
to attract investment but it does put
more of the ownership on
us the the electricity bill players in
the uk
but if they can satisfy the investment
community it's possible we'll get a
better deal besides we'll see and that's
part of what this this money is and
that's why it's significantly sending
that signal out there but they still
have a lot to prove i mean there are
some estimates that
hinckley point c is going to put 10 to
15 pounds on each of our energy bills
for the next 35 years we can't afford
something as expensive as that to happen
again
some people in the community are saying
where nuclear power really needs to go
uh beyond these two big plants uh and
possibly that third one in bradwell you
would you mentioned in the graphic is
for smaller modular reactors that are
less of a burden in terms of investment
but still low carbon and still a good
way of generating a basal electricity
supply to complement a grid that's got
lots of renewables on it as we move
towards net zero
now while the uk government intends to
continue using nuclear energy germany is
phasing it out altogether by the end of
this year it makes the country for now
at least dependent on coal and gas much
of which they get from russia well as
tensions between russia and ukraine
continue the nordstream 2 pipeline
project which will supply gas from
russia to germany
is being used to pressure moscow into
retreat our europe correspondent adam
parsons reports from lubman on the
northern coast of germany where the
pipeline makes landfall
it is windswept cold and empty here a
seaside resort out of season
but what happens in lugmin could yet be
crucial
there are echoes of soviet times a
former nuclear power plant stands idle
and ugly and russian influence is still
strong here this is the nordstream 2 gas
pipeline it links germany with russia
capable of supplying enough energy for
26 million german households it's either
a precious resource or a sign of
russia's creeping control or maybe both
angela merkel always insisted this was
just a commercial venture but in reality
nordstrom 2 is probably the most
contentious building project in the
world it's been opposed by a whole load
of leaders including donald trump and
successive ukrainian governments it ties
together germany and russia and now a
group of western allies including
britain and america
wants germany to unpick that knot to
accept the possibility of sanctions
against the russian energy industry even
the specter that nordstrom 2
could be shut down altogether
germany well remembers the pain of
conflict between east and west and
chancellor olive schultz has agreed only
reluctantly to embrace sanctions
including on nordstrom 2 that's a point
repeated today by his foreign minister
but he won't supply weapons to ukraine
his critics say he's too passive and
that his hesitancy has harmed germany's
reputation
i think the government should revisit
their position
and think about
supplying
weapon systems to the ukraine but when
it
when it comes
to germany we overcome
the
cold war because we could rely on others
now it's up to us to support the
countries which are now on the front
line
this is a rich country with ties to
russia and an ingrained sense of dread
of another war
among this group of ukrainians living in
berlin a sense of anxiety disappointment
we are like the allies we are like the
friends and we're not getting the
support and it's just very
sad and we also feel like powerless at
this point that
what should we do german government has
to
show clear position but also
active things that they can do
financial support also
support with supplies i think we need
sanctions on russia and to increase
these sanctions and to show with all
measures and possibilities that with
every russian aggressive step on
ukrainian border there will be like
harsh and quick answers and that is
germany's challenge to support its nato
allies without ostracizing its russian
gas suppliers but backing both horses is
never easy adam parsons sky news berlin
now for some of the day's other climate
news and the ftse 100 company mng plans
to invest up to half a billion pounds
over the next three to five years in
sustainable housing they've invested in
house builder green core construction
which currently has the capacity to
deliver 1 000 carbon positive homes in
the thames valley region with the new
funding green core says it will roll out
their carbon-positive homes to other
parts of the uk
the u.s environmental protection agency
has created new measures to tackle air
pollution and unsafe drinking water in
three gulf coast states
they'll install air monitoring equipment
in louisiana's chemical corridor and
will conduct unannounced inspections of
chemical plants in mississippi and texas
cancer risks in the region are far above
national levels with african americans
and other minority groups making up to
56 of those living there
more than one in five councils in the uk
have no climate action plan according to
climate emergency uk out of 325 council
plans that they scored only 86 of those
have set a net zero target of 2030 or
earlier and 33 of the councils had
failed to set a net zero target of 2050
or earlier
now a winter storm has brought extreme
weather to several countries in the
middle east the rare cold snap has
already caused disruption in the eastern
mediterranean and has brought services
across the region to a standstill well
in jerusalem the main roads in the city
were closed after as much as eight
inches of snow overnight and in jordan
the capital city of oman woke to a rare
blanket of overnight snow which blocked
roads and damaged the electricity
network and it's also affecting refugees
in northern syria on the turkey border
where three children have already died
in the freezing conditions our middle
east correspondent aleister bunkel
reports
it doesn't often snow in jerusalem but
the ancient city high up in the judean
hills is today covered in white
for jerusalemites it's an impromptu day
off
schools shops restaurants are all closed
this city that is so used to the sound
of division and disagreement is briefly
peaceful and quiet under its soft white
blanket
snowstorms have swept through the middle
east in recent days istanbul airport one
of the world's busiest all but shut down
earlier this week
in jordan the capital amman was also
brought to a standstill
the freak weather has created havoc in a
region more used to hot temperatures
occasionally the jet stream will get
weaker and sometimes it gets wobbly or
kind of bendy and that means that very
very cold polar air can travel much
further south than it normally does
you can compare it to when the uk has a
snow day and all trains cease to operate
just imagine that being in a country
which is really really unused to having
this kind of level of snowfall
there have been desperate scenes in
northern syria and lebanon
tens of thousands of refugees have spent
nights in freezing temperatures unable
to afford heating
hundreds of tents collapsed under the
snow making life even more miserable
at least three children have died in the
cold
well
the camp is very cold
the caravans are just like ice boxes
like a freezer
as soon as i turn on my heater it
becomes a freezer
can there be more suffering than this
the weather should get warmer again next
week it will open up a path for aid
workers to get urgent help to the
thousands who really need it
alastair bungalow sky news in jerusalem
coming up here on the daily climate show
i'll be joined by joycelyn london
founder of climate in color and richard
black senior associate and founder of
the energy and climate intelligence unit
and we're going to be discussing whether
taxpayer money should be spent on new
nuclear power stations and who are our
climate action role models
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
founder of climate and color joyce in
london and senior associate at the
energy and climate intelligence unit
richard black say hello to both of you
nice to see you both
so first of all the government is to
invest a hundred million pounds into
sizewell c a nuclear power station in
suffolk that will likely cost more than
20 billion pounds in total and take
nearly a decade to build so an important
vote of confidence in a low carbon power
source or would taxpayer money be better
spent elsewhere richard what do you
think do we need nuclear power has the
latest crisis over gas supply and rising
energy prices demonstrated a need for
for another source of homegrown energy
do you think
for it matters terribly much either way
to be honest um as tom was saying
earlier tom clark um you know there are
a lot of analysts who say that basically
britain would be better off with a
certain amount of nuclear power but you
have to remember that neither this nor
hinckley is going to come online for at
least a decade and so by then i suspect
that the energy system will look rather
different renewables will be even
cheaper than they are now i think
storage will be much cheaper than it is
now and those are much quicker and
easier to build as well so one thing i
think the government has been wise about
though is if it is going to build if it
does want nuclear power stations to be
built if it views these as a kind of
national asset then involve public money
because the costs of financing it are
just lower if you put the some of the
public welly behind it and that's one of
the reasons why this is projected to be
a little cheaper than the hinckley deal
well yes and monies always comes up in
the conversation doesn't it joycelyn but
what about this idea of of needing a low
carbon energy source that's reliable
whatever the weather i mean nuclear
fulfills that doesn't it what do you
make of it as an option
yeah of course um from a science
perspective nuclear is really important
because um currently we're in a position
to have a really stable renewable grid
um but i think i'm gonna echo what uh
richard just said about when this is
going to come online it's really not
part of our net zero uh target the the
timeline for them and also the expense
that needs to go into them they're more
of a legacy project um so i think we
need to be really intentional about
where we're putting a huge amount of our
focus and our priority into building
infrastructure and could that be going
into making a more reliable grid with
renewables as they are considering how
much quicker they have decreased in
price and increased increase in
reliability um nuclear has been around
for a very long time and we're still not
really getting uh the results that we
need um for this
low carbon grid um so those would be my
reservations yes and yet richard it's
really interesting to look at other
countries and their take on nuclear i
mean france obviously backs it
germany in the meantime is phasing out
its entire nuclear capacity isn't it and
partly over safety fears i mean it was
triggered after the fukushima um
disaster wasn't it that their
decision-making so what do you make of
what's going on in elsewhere in europe
well the german decision was actually
made first in the year 2000 and then
shortly before fukushima entirely
coincidentally the government decided to
elongate the lifetime of nuclear power
stations and then when we had fukushima
they reinstated the original date and
basically all the german nuclear
stations will be closed at the end of
this year really the german situation is
all to do with the cold war germany was
the frontline state in europe for a
possible nuclear conflict during the
cold war and that's
that's left and
that's left a definite imprint on the
german psyche and no one really in the
country is up for nuclear at all which
obviously from a climate change point of
view isn't great but i think given the
history of germany it's entirely
uh understandable there aren't many
countries in the world that plan to go
big on nuclear you look at china you
look at india but even then their
nuclear ambitions are dwarfed by their
renewable ambitions and as we saw china
you know installed a vast amount of
offshore wind um uh last year and then
you've got a few of the countries like
france as you as you said but really on
a global scale one expects the share of
nuclear electricity to be dwindling and
that's for a whole number of reasons but
i think number one is the cost and the
ease of building renewables a very quick
thought from you jocelyn on this i mean
are you saying basically you just like
the money all spent on renewables
um it's not that the money should all be
spent on renewables you have to remember
that the climate crisis isn't just about
energy and it's not a sort of one-issue
crisis we obviously have to spend money
in lots of different places but it's
just prioritizing how much of that money
and because the money in it kind of
shows the public what the uh focus is
for the government and so it should be
proportional to what is really working
and what is really going to get us to
the targets to ensure that customers and
the public really understand what is uh
what has efficacy and what works and
what is going to get us to our targets
okay let's move on to our next topic and
we're asking who are the role models
that we look up to on climate action
today and we're asking this because of
the sad news this week of the death of
sir crispin takel at the age of 91. that
he was a diplomat an environmentalist
who had the ear of margaret thatcher and
wrote a book in 1977 called climactic
change and world affairs which argued
for an international treaty on pollution
and richard i understand that you did
know crispin to kell so tell us a little
bit about him and how influential you
think he was in changing minds on
climate policy
yes i spent a bit of time with him in
the last decade basically when we opened
the energy and climate intelligence unit
um in 2014 so crispin was one of a
number of people who came onto our
advisory board um and he was he was
extremely interesting guy very urbane
very diplomatic in that sense of word
had a wry sense of humor but his impact
both on the uk and internationally i
think is far greater than his public
profile as as you said you know he
convinced margaret thatcher basically
that climate change was a serious issue
in 1989 she devoted her entire annual
speech to the u.n general assembly to
the environmental crisis and it's a
fantastic speech i would urge anyone to
go and read it now margaret thatcher was
a scientist herself and one of the
things that crispin said to me was that
when they talked about any other issue
she
was a politician when they talked about
climate change she acted as a scientist
so basically without that the history of
the uk uh involvement the cross-party
consensus the involvement of the
conservative party in climate change
would have been very different and if
she had not called for a un treaty in
that speech in 1989 perhaps we wouldn't
have a united nations climate convention
so joyce it's really interesting isn't
it that there are figures like this that
seem to have had a big impact would you
agree that it it's generally speaking
government advisors and government
ministers who have the most impact
because they're changing policy or do
you think we should give a shout out to
celebrities or influences that start
shifting public opinion which puts
pressure on politicians who would you
say are the best most effective role
models at the moment
i think i would have to disagree with
both i think we're missing a huge trick
in understanding that climate leadership
and climate impact is not equivalent to
status and that value doesn't come with
visibility and there are lots of climate
leaders
who don't have any status who aren't
known at all who are really making huge
changes um either they are pushing
policy in local governments they are
putting their own actual bodies in front
of um
kind of people who are destruction
destructing um our world um and there
are people in workplaces in homes in
schools who are also leading this and i
think that sometimes we get a bit
distracted by those in the forefront and
sometimes we actually rely on them to do
a lot of the heavy lifting without
realizing that we could also be climate
leaders and take up that position as
well richard do you think that's right
that actually some of the real heroes
are people we've never heard of
yeah i think there's an awful lot of
real heroes that we never we we we hear
of i was thinking of some of the uk
diplomats for example who've been
involved in cop 26 who worked all the
hours that were you know there were on
this earth over there over the last year
and probably their names aren't known
very much outside their own lunch times
as the
as the um as the saying goes i think
basically you know you've got three
constituencies that are vitally
important here one's the public one is
politicians and government and the other
is business and you can find examples of
real leadership uh in all of them just
take one example electric cars why are
we now going to a situation where
motoring is going to be electric we've
had scientific and technical innovations
we've had groups like greenpeace who are
ahead of the time arguing for these
things we've had a norwegian government
that grasped the metal grassed the
nether story and went ahead and
implemented it and showed it could be
done and we've had business leaders like
elon musk who have really changed the
entire business and investment
conversation about electric cars so it's
the whole mix there so joyce would you
agree with that you're nodding away
there we should give credit to people
across the board
yes i think we need to realize that you
know climate change and the climate
action and actually any social action
that's happened in the past although
there seemed to be um these kind of
figureheads or people at the um helm of
the um of the auction it's actually a
really huge group effort and there are
so many different perspectives that come
in so many different parts of that
action that have huge domino effects on
what actually ends up happening in the
end um and we need to really keep that
in mind otherwise you know we we do
those people a disservice who have put
so much hard work into bringing these
together and we reduce the problems that
we have we reduce the complexity and the
amount of different perspectives and
skills that we need to fix our issues
okay well joycelyn london richard black
always fascinating to get your views
thanks very much indeed for joining us
well tomorrow i'll be joined by
environmental activist judy lin wong and
editor-in-chief of business green james
murray so join us for that but for today
thanks for watching see you next time
[Music]
you